all right I'm really really excited
because I get to talk about like two
things that I love the most in the world
which is animating in view today a lot
of people are probably not that familiar
with you so I'm gonna actually talk
about what it is as I talk about how to
animate in it just in case you're not
familiar yeah so like I said my name is
Sarah Dresner this is a picture of me
picking my nose as a child and also my
relationship with Authority um my poor
mother that's how you find me on Twitter
at Sarah IDO
I used to be a consultant until recently
which did not mean that I was unemployed
I worked with a lot of really wonderful
companies including Smashing but
recently I took a job as a senior cloud
developer advocate at Microsoft so
that's pretty cool and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about some of those things
today okay before we dig into how we
animated in view maybe we should talk
about why we're animating at all
strangely enough our story starts with
performance when people visit a site we
have something called the so what factor
user attention is really short and we
have about two seconds before it fully
drops off Amazon's discovered that for
every one second delay conversions drop
by seven percent
Walmart found that it gains one percent
revenue increase for every 100
milliseconds of improvement and if
someone waits for your site for over
four seconds they they express from MRI
reports we know that they feel the same
kind of visceral reaction that they do
when they watch a horror film so I guess
this would be if you were watching
Burger King site load or something like
that but perceived performance is a way
that animation can help when we're
working with web sites humans actually
overestimate passive wait times by 36%
Eli Fitch gave a great talk at CSS def
Kampf last year called perceived
performance the only kind of performance
that matters which i think is a really
really great title and it's true because
the way that we perceive how long things
are taking really really does matter
in terms of performance and it matters
in terms of how long customers will wait
for us so your benchmarks if you're
using Google Chrome timeline or
something like that aren't really
telling you the full story so begat did
an experiment and found that despite
some individual variation when they
tried two different loaders on their
site people who are willing to wait
twice as long for a custom loader so if
you look at these two loaders but we get
loader that ended up being twice as long
it's not so fancy it's not so incredible
but it does tell the users it gives them
a signal that somebody cares about them
so what's happening here here's heat
maps of your eye as it goes across a
website so we have all of these
different pieces of attention it's
moving your eyes are moving around
constantly an event called saccade they
never stay in looking at one place and
you do this to create spatial awareness
you do this to kind of understand you
know the environment around you you're a
predator so you're trying to look at the
environment and see if something's
changing so you can eat something or if
something's gonna come and eat you so
you can run away so anytime something
changes in that environment you have to
remap that mental space I really love
this quote it's we've evolved to perform
actions that flow more or less
seamlessly we aren't wired to deal with
the fits and starts of human-computer
interaction so things naturally
transition the flamenco dancers didn't
just like pop up on the stage they
walked out onto the stage and you kind
of knew where they were coming from and
where they're going to and that is
really true that's how we're trained to
see things so we're not if you're
working like looking at a site on mobile
and all of a sudden a modal pops up in
your face you're distracted you're
probably gonna click away from it it
doesn't feel like a good experience so
we've actually evolved to think that
anything that pops out that pops out at
us is actually a little bit frightening
with anything that kind of comes into
our purview without us knowing about it
first
is not something that is generally you
know accepted very easily by our
evolutionary biology so here's an
example of how we can gain spatial
awareness and understanding on the web
here we're this is an example from code
drops and we're just picking our seats
at a movie theater but you get a real
understanding of what that experience
would look like and what it would feel
like and even if you change things in
that environment they guide you
seamlessly from one transition to
another without transitions we lose an
opportunity the user has to remap all of
that space and it doesn't feel as fluid
it feels a little bit more clunky in
Paul Bacchus illusion of speed he maps
about he talks about how users map that
small interactions if there's a lot of
them are perceived as very long and one
continuous activity is perceived as very
short so I made this pen to kind of
explore that and see what that might
look like so we've got this pin that
opens it up into a contact form labels
move out of the way to gather input and
then they become the loaders that in
turn become the success now if I asked
you where's the contact form you would
say it's in there but there's no in
there it's all just divs and form
elements and they're absolutely
positioned and things like that but
because you have a sense of that you
know physical space and because you have
a sense that that just comes out and has
one long continuous activity it doesn't
feel like there were four different
modal's that are hopping in your face it
feels like one fluid activity
so before we animate in view we're gonna
talk about actually like so many ways to
animate in view today and like just like
a myriad of ways there's one that's
really really important that's the
transition component we're gonna spend a
little bit more time with that one but
it's important to understand that I'm
not gonna make you learn every single
way down to the T I'm just kind of
wetting your palate for all of the
things available to you for you to dig
into later so we're gonna talk about how
we work with you we're gonna talk about
that transition component that I
mentioned we're gonna talk about the
Watchers and the reactivity system so
you understand what those are we're
going to talk about SVG of course
because I love SVG
we're gonna talk about coordinating
state with view ex and lifecycle methods
and animations versus custom directives
and also server-side rendering okay
let's start with the basics so just a
tiny comparison if you're not aware of
what View is or does at all it offers a
virtual Dom it is a reactive it offers
reactive components that offer the view
layer only so you know angular is
reactive but it's an MVC view is a V
like just like reactive it's just the
view
it offers props and a redock Redux like
store just like react does it offers
conditional rendering services similar
to angular and it's inspired by polymer
for simplicity and performance so you're
writing HTML CSS and JavaScript in
tandem basically Avenue the person who
wrote this framework looked at the
entire landscape of JavaScript
frameworks and and took out the bits
that he thought were you know like
essential and the the things that he
loved most about each of them and put
them together in a kind of elegant way
all right
so let's do the obligatory hello world
example before we dig in any further so
here we you can see we instantiate a
view instance we'll create a
relationship with that div ID app and
then we'll be holding the we are holding
the state for the app instead of like
but jQuery days of old where we're
pinging the Dom to see what's changing
we're holding the state so in this case
it can be text it can be numbers it can
be anything so we can output this in
those mustache templates above and it's
pretty simple so let's do a really light
comparison of vanilla JavaScript versus
view with conditional rendering so let's
see we have like a big ole list and this
is probably something that like an API
is giving us or like we're paying a
server for things in our in our case
we're just like holding an array of
things so we're going to translate that
to a list in our Dom if we're getting
that thing from the server how do we do
that with vanilla JavaScript so okay
well create a simple array and then
we're going to create a function
and we're we're gonna basically like
make a for loop with that list and then
we're gonna go grab something out of the
Dom and we're gonna insert those things
into the list and we're gonna be able to
access it that way but it's pretty
imperative we're gonna call that
function and then we're actually gonna
add that to the Container so there's a
bunch of things that we have to do we're
really following things like steps in a
recipe it eventually this kind of way of
working can get a little bit convoluted
because if anything changes we're gonna
say hey Dom what's going on over there
and like go ask it for things so you
know this outputs this like very very
simple list that we have here but in a
view instance we store the data we are
storing the state of the thing and we're
holding that information and then in our
div ID app we say L IV for item and
items and we output all of the items and
then we have this whole list printed to
the page it's really really clean and
easy to read and there's not a lot that
you have to do to grok that information
so I love this approach because it's
clean its semantic I really like writing
semantic code it's easy to maintain as a
consultant I love you because I can walk
into a project and I can know exactly
where everything is and I don't have to
understand a ton of context before
digging in it's really declarative you
saw we're like making the computer do a
lot of the heavy lifting so we can
easily read and work with the data
it's very legible and because it's
legible it's easy to maintain you know
because I can look at it really really
simply and very easily between states I
know exactly what I need to do to update
it so it's also reactive which I won't
dig into yet but we have a whole part of
this talk that will we'll dig into that
so you might be wondering why I'm
showing you a picture of an iPhone I'm
not gonna talk about mobile dev I'm just
showing you a phone because I remember
getting my first iPhone it was the
sophisticated piece of equipment and
some of the best engineers in the world
work on it and I felt like it was really
really powerful but when I was using it
I never felt pandered - I felt like
everything was at my fingertips and I
didn't need an
struction manual or anything to figure
out where everything lived or where
everything worked how or how everything
worked that's pretty much how I feel
when I use view it's very very similar I
think sometimes people think of
simplicity as meaning that it's not
powerful but view feel simple while
giving you all of this lower level
access to all of these really really
fundamental things that you can do that
are really really powerful ok so let's
talk about the v-model really quickly
there's a ton of directives in view but
this one is pretty interesting so it can
kind of give you a sense of what
directives do before we start making
some animation custom directives in a
bit so in order to keep you productive
we get these things like like v-model
which gives us access to deeper
functionality so these directives keep
us from yak shaving they keep us from
having to re-implement the same thing
that we're always implementing over and
over again so what it does is it
establishes a relationship with an input
so on every keystroke we're recording
those changes in updating them in our
state so we're accepting that user input
so again we've got that element of the
app and then we have like a string like
this is good place to type things then
with our v-model directive we're
creating a relationship there and you
can see it's still like normal text area
and normal things like rows and max
length and classes and then we're going
to output whatever people are typing
there so if we're writing here and I'm
writing gonna write really slowly I'm
writing here and it's automatically
updating it's automatically updating for
us and it's all automatically updating
for the way that people are typing
things and so you can do things very
quickly to user input which is a pretty
common use case on the web so in terms
of animation because this relationship
was established with so much ease you
can do advanced effects because all
you're doing is wrapping one component
and only dealing with what's going to
happen during those animation States so
you already know how half of this demo
works and by the end of the talk you'll
know how the other half works too tada
okay so let's talk about the transition
component for a second so if we have
something like a modal we have like the
app child which is our modal and we have
this button that's going to basically
toggle the visibility of it then the
inside view we have something like you
know whether it's showing or not and
we're gonna toggle that based on that
button activity and so if we click it
then okay the thing appears that's
that's okay but it's I just mentioned
it's not so great when something just
pops into your face so what do we do
with this app child well we'll just wrap
it we're just gonna wrap it in this one
element called transition and I'm gonna
give it a name and then I have all of
these hooks with which to work with
views got done a really really good job
of understanding these transitions of
state because the guy who wrote it is
really really into animations so you can
see we have different ways of hooking
into this the V enter active and the V
leave active those are the places those
are the hooks where we can put all of
our animation logic so our transitions
go there our CSS animation go there our
JavaScript animation goes there and the
enter and the enter two are just what
you want it to do right before the
animation kicks off what you want it to
do right after the animation kicks off
so before it enters right after it's
done entering and so on and so forth so
if we wanted to do a simple transition
we just plug into that v enter active
and all we'd have to say is you know
transition color when one second easy
that's really all we need to start
making that transition happen so it's
reusable for other components too it's
pretty typical use case that we want to
toggle some visibility so we've got the
interactive via be leave active and
we've got that transition and then we're
saying what we want it to go to so now
when I click it it's a little bit better
we see a little bit more of that
transition which is great but what would
happen if we wanted to make that
background content kind of fade out and
that you know the modal take center
stage that we're not seeing
we're not trying to grok all the
information of what's in the background
so we could use the transition component
but we'd have to wrap the whole
background and what we really want to do
is just transition a little bit of style
for that so view actually
makes that really easy too so what we
can do is we can say something like if
it's showing use a blur class if not
don't and then we're also using that
transition component and we have you
know this like little filter on the
background that's just a blur of two
pixels and as we trigger that you can
see that the background is now fading so
that's cool
but there's much more that view has to
offer in this transition component and
one of the coolest parts is this thing
called transition modes so it's pretty
common that you want something to
transition into the Dom and then you
want something else to transition out so
usually what ends up happening is those
things are present in the Dom at the
same time when they're both fading like
there's just a second where they're both
like me that's the technical term and so
what what you really want to end up
doing is you want to either insert a
callback if you're working with
JavaScript that like waits for one thing
to finish and then the other thing to
enter or if you're using CSS animation
you'd make like an impose delay between
those two things so that they're not
present in the Dom and at the same time
so these transition modes will allow you
to coordinate these two things without
even touching any of these things
without writing any kind of imperative
code so if we have something like this
these are two elements but because
they're you know using these transition
modes one is fading out completely and
it's just turning this way and then the
other one is turning this way at the
exact same time because view is
coordinating all of that for us and it
looks like one consistent experience I'm
just telling it to you know as soon as
that one comes out this other one's
coming in and without that we kind of
lose an opportunity it's not the biggest
thing in the world but you might have
seen this a lot online basically both of
them are doing the same thing at the
same time and you're missing one of
those animations because it's hidden
behind the other one so in out for a
transition mode the current element
waits until the new element is done
before coming in and firing and out in
is the current element transitions out
and then the new element transitions in
usually you're just gonna use out in
like don't even try with the other one
unless you really need it like most of
the time you just need out in so this is
what
are what we like that thing that we just
flipped over this is what that looks
like all I do is say on the transition
itself mode out in and it coordinates
the state for us so pretty cool all
right so we got through transitions
let's talk about CSS animation all right
so it's still the transition component
we're still using that same transition
component but we can use different
classes for that so we can reuse
animation we can plug in to CSS
animation libraries if we want there's a
lot of flexibility here so if we want
this bat ball to bounce and then roll
out we can say something like you know
interactive class is bouncing interleave
class is roll out and then the bounce is
I'm just basically you know you have to
use transforms in order to make things
really performant for the web so I'm
just drying it out with a mixin and
using that and then I can use that
bounce for other things so if you have
something like a fade that you're using
over and over again you can keep it very
consistent across a large code base okay
so now let's get to some JavaScript
hooks because there's some really cool
things that you can do with JavaScript
all right so we've still got that
transition component and but we have all
of these kind of different ways of
hooking into it you'll notice that we
say CSS false that allows you to know
like hey don't go looking in the CSS for
this go look in the JavaScript instead
and we have all of these hooks available
to us but really most likely all we need
is this enter and leave that's usually
what I end up using so basically it's
that same transition component again but
now if I go into my methods in view I
have that enter and the leave available
to me we're also going to pass in a
zapper am
we want to allow it to you know
basically tell view when the animation
is done so I can do things like
coordinate those transition modes so now
this demo that you saw before you kind
of know how it works we can hook up
v-model
and animate the text on in a really
playful manner so what that looks like
for you know the transition component is
this before enter enter CSS false and
then in view itself we have this these
modes so we've got this before enter I
could
so put this in my CSS actually it's just
setting CSS properties on it but the
reason why I do put it in my JavaScript
and this is a stylistic thing this isn't
working with you is that transform
transform perspective perspective and
transform style are all things that
affect it the element while it's
animating it doesn't make the thing look
any different before it's animating so
people might come in and be like hey
what's this code for I don't know why
this is in the CSS if I remove it it
doesn't do anything to the element and
then they can if we're all maintaining
the codebase together they're like I'm
an engineer who likes deleting code
let's delete code and then all of a
sudden your animation doesn't work so a
lot of times I'll tie those together so
it's a little bit more obvious to people
maintaining after me that those are
connected so and then in order to make
it enter in you know and scatter around
basically I'm telling you know tween max
which is a green sock animation API to
take it from this area and bounce it
around and I'm basically giving it this
like randomized Z you know index and
kind of like throwing out all over the
page and that's how it bounces into the
view I also if you're working with
something that has a timeline like green
sock or like mo dot J s you'll want to
pass in something like uncomplete done
into the instance itself they have those
hooks so use the animation the the
timeline hooks that are available for
each library that's just like gotcha
that I wanted to mention okay transition
group is also really fun and this one is
a huge time-saver so let's dig into that
really quickly so there's this thing
called flip how many of you are familiar
with flip in animation not a lot
very few okay so basically what you're
doing with flip because transforms are
more important than changing things with
whit's and tight tops and left's you
basically if you have this component and
it's going to change or this element and
it's going to change position it's gonna
change in size you're gonna get the
bounding client rect of that thing and
you're gonna get it of the other thing
and you're gonna figure out the space in
between and transition those so flip
stands for lat first last invert
play and it's a way to get really smooth
animations on the web and it's a way to
ensure that you're always using
transforms in order to calculate those
things but the trouble is and maybe you
got this from me just explaining it it's
really hard to implement it's kind of a
pain in the butt basically you have to
go get those coordinates you have to
calculate all of those things for each
element and when you start to have a lot
of elements this is this turns out to be
really arduous so for one element it's
kind of okay for hundred elements it's a
bit of a pain and it's a little clunky
to write so view offers us this thing
called transition group and what it's
going to do is it's going to just give
us all of that flip under the hood for
free it's going to figure it out for us
so if we have something like this lazy
Sudoku where all of these elements are
constantly moving around on the page all
of that flip activity is going to happen
and we don't have to do any of that view
is going to do all the logic for us and
basically you just keep shuffling this
until you win this is an example from
the guide ok so another thing that we
can do is we can leverage the reactivity
system for animations and transitions so
view is really awesome because it
actually grants us deeper access into
the reactivity system which we can
leverage for asynchronous updates
animations or transitions so let's talk
about Watchers really quickly and that's
that's the thing that we're gonna plug
into before we do so it's kind of
important to talk about what reactive
programming is because I think it's
really confusing to a lot of people and
a lot of people are you know not really
sure what it is and they're like oh well
it's rxjs well yeah ok rxjs
is a type of reactive programming it is
you know they're if reactive programming
is like a big umbrella it like fits
inside of there but there's tons of ways
to be reactive so let's talk about what
reactive is and means reactive
programming is programming with
asynchronous data streams ok like come
on what is it what does that mean
basically you can think of a stream as a
series of ongoing events ordered in time
that you can start to plug in some hooks
with which to observe it so a really
common
example of this is if you're in Excel
and you have two cells and you just say
okay make the sum of these in another
cell just whatever those two might be so
if you went back to one of the first
cells and you changed one of those
numbers it would still give you the sum
at the end that's because we've put in a
hook to watch that other thing
so basically reactivity and reactive
programming allows us to program
asynchronous code as if it was
synchronous and makes it a lot more
clear what's going on so when we use
reactive premesis for building
applications this makes it really easy
to update state in reaction to events
which is usually what we're doing when
we're programming applications that's
usually what we have to do and results
has a really good post about this by the
way that's the link so what is reactive
I think people are kind of confused
still like who uses reactive programming
what it is actually everybody uses it a
little bit differently angular 1.x has
dirty checking cycle and angular to use
things that are similar to extreme and
rxjs view mount mob x and r active all
used getters and setters and here's the
one of the weirdest ones despite the
name react is not reactive it uses a
pole approach rather than a push
approach so if you are we're not going
to dive into this any further I just
wanted to make all that clear
if you want more resources and to dig in
further there are some links ok
so we've got this thing called Watchers
in view I mentioned that that's how
we're gonna plug into the reactivity
system so we're gonna watch any data
property declared on the view instance
and you can see every time we update
this
I'm just console logging because that
watch is on the counter it's basically
using something that's in our data and
it gives us something to plug into
anytime this thing changes give me some
access to it so that's really good for
animation because state change can
create the animation so here we're using
Watchers we're basically spinning up a
chart with SVG and we're you know
transitioning that state with Watchers
we're telling it anytime you see this
thing updating these numbers updating
change them for us you know and and you
these kind of animation tools in this
way of doing it in order to do this and
SVG is really good what for this because
it's built with math so I made all of
this chart without any library like d3
or Chartist or anything and could avoid
that whole thing because we have all of
those directives that I showed you
earlier so if you know SVG well enough
you don't even need a big library you
can just output it because it's built
with math so I have these kind of like V
if and you know that kind of stuff that
you saw earlier and then I'm able to
spin up an entire axis with very very
little code that's really really fun and
we don't have two plugins or Watchers to
transition the state either because we
can we're already plugging into the
state all the time anyway you saw that
we were binding those classes so view
offers us class and style bindings and
at you know SVG is really good at with
this so we can you know use some SVG and
make this weird Tron you know effects in
this Tron like pen and really all we're
doing here is we're saying X and y are 0
and this dot X and this dot y are
plugging into e client X so wherever our
mouse is going to be and then oh then no
my slides died ok give me one second
all right we're back in business sorry
for the delay there there we go all
right now if we want to track progress
all we have to say is perspective origin
and then we changing the percentage of
those prospective origins in our
template it's such a small amount of
code to make that crazy effect that we
just saw so SVG animation and view play
really nicely together because we're
still working with the HTML the way that
we are normally working with it so we've
got you know this little Wally that's
kind of moving across he's gonna go try
to find his like a little cockroach
friend which is the mouse and he's
reaching out so basically the way that
this is this is working is we've got
this Wally guy and he's kind of looking
around while stuff and we've got an
animation that I did the whole animation
of but I'm gonna plot the progress of
the animation along with that a client X
that you just saw so as pops out that's
what's going on and emotions are tied to
your limbic system so anytime you make
your you feel something they're gonna
remember it a lot better later so in the
view template itself we have at mouse
movement coordinates and then you know
so anytime we have a now a mousemove
event we plug in two coordinates and
then basically I'm doing some logic to
figure out where the mouse is and how to
plug this timeline into the progress of
that thing and then it allows him to
move around also in order to make his
arms move in and out and this is an SVG
thing I'm using this clip path in his
arm that's allowing you to see pieces of
the arm as it goes in and out
so because SVG and view play well
together we can do all sorts of things
with form elements we're gonna use all
of those lovely view directives that we
saw earlier and manipulate and interact
with SVG on the fly as well
so since SVG has a navigable Dom we can
spin up pieces on the fly change its
visual output and of course play and
pause animation as we or they wish the
user wishes and since SVG is flexible it
can be interactive
and we can write things in it and play
with all sorts of different ways of
working with it but it's also still an
image format so whatever we make on the
fly we can also download and the graphic
will even respect all of the animation
transforms that were applied while we
were creating it as well pretty cool so
we've got you know these create big
circles and small circles those input
elements and then we're basically
spinning up all of these ways to work
with those elements onto the page on the
fly and because SVG so small we can do
it super fast the user won't even notice
that something is loading okay so let's
coordinate a few transitions so far all
of our animations have been in lockstep
with one of one another in terms of our
application but what if we have a giant
application and there's a bit of state
that state that's stored and we don't
want to pass it up and down from parent
to child well we can use a thing called
view X which is similar to Redux if
you're familiar with react and you can
use these you know these kind of events
to work with animation as well so just
to let you know you can use Redux in a
View application if you you know so
wished it is compatible but view X is
very similar to and it's you know also
made for that framework so it's up to
you so if we have something like this
where we have you know a component where
there you know there's a bunch of
different components being loaded based
on the state
and once we've encapsulated what we're
changing the component each owns its own
state so the entrance will be consistent
as well as the exit so we can change
their order and we can change their
placement in time anything we'd like to
do with it
so in this example I have this idea in
the main store of these screens or
templates and you know once we get to
the last one we loop around and go back
to the first and then for the components
themselves we're basically saying if
we're at one you know fire this
component if we're at to fire that
component and we're using a lifecycle
method to do so so view allows us grants
us access to do things when the
component is mounted react does allows
us to do that too so it's like component
didn't mount in react and it would be
mounted in view so we're allowing a
timeline and a bunch of animation to
occur on those lifecycle methods so if
you have this thing where you have a
component and there's a bunch of things
that are happening like basically the
component is being put on the page we
have all these hooks and that we're
allowed to use so like before create
created before mount mounted and then
before destroy destroyed there's all
sorts of things that we can plug into to
make animations occur all right but
let's talk about custom directives
because those are pretty cool so we had
that directive that v-model thing and
that's really cool and so as the V if
you know just being able to say I need
some lower level access to do something
to run some logic but what if you want
to make your own what if like that what
they have available to you doesn't cover
your uses and you're kind of writing
things over and over again
well view allows it you to register
these custom components so let's do one
together so here's how we would create a
custom view directive it's probably most
common to hook into bind so we've
created a custom directive called attack
it's actually not that useful yet all
we're doing is setting position fixed so
let's try to do one better we can pass a
value into the directive make it a bit
more flexible
and then we can tell the v-tach
directive to stick this element 70 you
know 70 pixels from the top of the page
now we can pass an argument so if we
don't specify anything it'll be tacked
to the top otherwise it'll be tacked to
the left and that's a little bit better
so you know we have a little bit more
room to like work with it and you know
try different things with it but can we
do better of course we can so now we can
do more than one value and we can say
okay we want one thing for the top and
one thing for the left and they can pass
that in separately we could also keep
going and do it you know right and
bottom as well and now we have something
that's like really flexible so let's
apply that to animation in this example
we'll create a directive that attaches
to a scroll event so it allows you to
attach functionality to that scroll
event and do some animation and then it
will allow you to remove the listener so
you might be familiar with like scroll
magic or scroller or waypoints there's
tons of libraries that do these kind of
things and they're all huge now we can
write you know a few lines of code have
this directive available to us and you
know be able to use it whenever we want
so now we can do something like have
this little scroll event trigger this
like beautiful animation that comes up
so now in the I'm in the process of
making this demo which is like a little
sneak peek of it but basically it's
working with those custom that custom
directive that you saw earlier and
plugging into d3s functionality so I'm
allowed to do these things with
scrolling telling where I plug into
NASA's information for fireballs and
like as you're scrolling down the page
there's all sorts of things that happen
with just such a small amount of code to
do so so we're up we're going to update
all of the circles coordinates so we're
basically like plugging into that
directive that you saw earlier and
changing all of these attributes if
you're not familiar with d3 all these
attr that's just changing a bunch of
attributes of things that are already
exist on the page
okay page transitions is the one of the
last things that we're gonna do page
transitions is one of those things
that's like kind of a bummer because
it's kind of hard to implement it's
really difficult to get things to kind
of coordinate on pages and it looks so
nice when you're on mobile when you're
like on a native app and things are
transitioning very fluidly from one
thing to another but it's harder to do
on the web but there's this thing called
next that allows you to work with with
view kind of similar to that next with
react and it has this CLI so it spins up
this whole application for you right out
of the box and gives you page
transitions out of the box too with no
configuration it also allows you to do
server-side rendering out of the box too
which is really nice because by
rendering on the server you can cache
the final shape of your data which
basically means that you can increase
the speed of your site and not you know
allow additional requests to the server
to bog down your site so here's a way
that we can actually have code splitting
and server-side rendering all with this
one terminal step so we would install
this thing called view CLI and then from
our terminal we'd say view in it nook
starter my project and then we have this
thing that we can work with so you'll be
given an index page in the pages
directory and if you dump that content
and create a simple you know view file
with a next link and you can have those
links point to one another you have
routing already available to you which
is really nice so basically this pages
directory allows you to still work with
view files in order to create routing
you don't ever have to step out of that
way of working with components it's so
easy to work with and they already give
you a hook for it so you don't even have
to make a transition component or
anything you can just hook into this
page interactive you just write a bit of
CSS and you can transition between pages
entering and pages leaving which i think
is like another tada like that is so
awesome you don't have to do a lot of
things to create these beautiful effects
and you don't just have to use
transitions we can create animations too
don't never never animate like this I'm
just doing it so that you can see it
purposes of the demo if you have this
like this small amount of information on
page you got a kind of show people have
been a more flamboyant way yeah don't
come out of the session and be like
Sarah told me that oh I'm throwing my my
things around because it's at the end of
the talk and I'm just like okay we're
ready for a break now
so we're gonna create some animations -
we also have those JavaScript hooks
available to us so we have those modes
like the out in so we can basically tell
the page wait till it's done
transitioning out before you let the
next page transition in that's a big one
and then you can do all sorts of things
with it like what we were doing before
so here we can create really steep
seamless and stylish page transitions
that change per page so they're not even
transitioning the same way every time
the text and all of the mountains and
everything that are in the background
are transitioning in a different way and
because it's all done with SVG it's also
really really stable when we go to
mobile and I didn't have to write a lot
of media queries for that either it's
just like you know changing based on the
container so this all of this is done
with such a small amount of like futzing
and figuring out all of this code so the
repo to explore that code is there and
there's like a live demo that you can go
play with and the last thing that we're
gonna talk about and which will take two
seconds I promise and then you'll be
able to go eat and drink and be merry as
I mentioned before I worked for
Microsoft as a developer advocate and
people often ask us developer advocates
where we're speaking next and what
cities were going to so I made this demo
that allows you to play with serverless
functions and views so I'm using Azure
service functions to get all of the
geolocation data for that globe so
serverless is one of these like terrible
click-click beatty titles for something
that's actually pretty interesting and
basically what it allows us to do is run
a small function on the server without
babysitting the server we're not scaling
anything or anything so I'm gonna ping
the Google the Google Maps API and get
that data and then I can go and create
whole globe and I'm using three.js for
that globe so I have a single element
and then on mounted remember that
lifecycle hook we had earlier we're
gonna call the logic for that globe and
pass in the texture of that globe that
we saw earlier and because view and
three j/s play together so nicely not
that you'd want to do this but if you
wanted to change the the appearance of
that globe all you'd have to do is
change one line of code I could just
change the sphere geometry to the ice I
saw Saheed Rijn I can't say it because
it's like the led to the end of the top
but that's just one line of code in
order to get these kind of really really
amazing effects so view makes it
extraordinarily simple to create complex
and beautiful interactions for the web
that feel really seamless for our users
we can connect states and reduce
cognitive load for things that are
changing in our app with ease and also
on a personal note sometimes when you're
maintaining large scale applications and
working with all of these components
corporate deadlines can really start to
burn you out this happened to me and by
working with stuff like animation that
gives you and your users these dopamine
rushes of excitement you can stave off
burnout and still continual can you
continually remember why we love working
with the web so damn much thank you so
much